brought to you by Bioshock the
collection the Bioshock games should it
teach us a lot
for example that wrenches and
electricity are a match made in heaven
but slamming your fists onto a button is
the only way to call an elevator and
that eating food out of bins is not only
socially acceptable but beneficial to
your health
all right bin cake know if it's good
enough for Lavine it's good enough for
me
so this week on in two minutes brought
to you by bioshock the collection here's
seven things you probably didn't know
about the five shot games i promise that
all of the points aren't just the
bioshock 2 is criminally underrated even
though it is the original picture
bioshock promised quite a different game
you'd play as Carlos cuéllar a deep
programmer assigned to rescue a wealthy
heiress from the clutch of a religious
cult you'd be able to hack the
environment adding more oxygen in the
air would increase the blast radius of
explosions you can magnetize the floor
to slow down robots or increase room
temperature to make you invisible to
thermal security sweeps plasmids came in
quite a different form you'd harvest
genotypes from animals like jellyfish or
eels and merge them with your body to
create a gross hybrid monster and
speaking of gross originally the
adorable little sisters were sea slugs
yep sea slugs when the studio realized
that no one would empathize with the
slimy things Irrational's artists try to
come up with something cuter like this
sad dog in a wheelchair and the infamous
frog with a funnel in its anus yes
really
a few plasmids were cut from the
original BioShock during development
speed booster would have boosted speed
for a short amount of time it was cut
from Bioshock 1 but reappeared as arrow
- in bio 2's multiplayer teleportation
was cut quite late in development it
allowed the player to place a beacon
which they could instantly return to it
was removed because it re Tabak was
scripted events in some cases allowing
players to miss entire sections of the
game the slow pro would have been a
slow-moving projectiles shootin range
Big Daddy that had a huge cannon
mounted on its shoulder it was cut from
the original BioShock as the developers
thought it was a little too colorful and
didn't fit the tones of the game but it
resurfaced in bio to as the rumbler Big
Daddy throughout Bioshock Infinite's
five-year development irrational games
were said to have cut 5 or 6 video games
worth of content from the final product
in fact almost nothing from the original
III trailer makes it into the final game
the character of Elizabeth changed a
whole bunch originally she and Booker
would be mute and concept I showed that
she would be much older in early
trailers we saw that Elizabeth abilities
were way more powerful on top of psycho
telekinetic powers she could even raise
storms but by the time that infinite
roll round her powers were limited the
only being able to open and close tears
originally the more you used her powers
the more she would be harmed
this would offer players a kind of risk
reward element to the gameplay as well
as change the outcome of the story kind
of right the choice to harvest or save
the little sisters back in Bioshock 1
so there we are seven things you
probably didn't know about the Bioshock
games any surprises in there let me know
in the comments below I definitely
wasn't expecting Mia anus funnel anyway
you can find me on Twitter at Lucy James
games and until next time I'll be eating
this bin gig see you then